[Music]
let's talk about Becca season where are
we in the filming at this point maybe Rd
rap we're done I know everything it's
not yeah we just wrapped which is why
I'm able to be here and May 28th is our
premiere it's right around the corner
it's so damn good it's such a great
season she's a great Bachelorette that
guys are great the drama is there the
tears the ridiculous arguments it's good
it's really good we already know that
two men in like the very first episode
get into a crazy fight over the reasons
of being there are these guys the most
hot-headed group we've had so far I
don't know that they're up there they
get it may be the most ridiculous fight
you've ever seen in the history of our
show which is saying a lot I mean there
are some just inane comments made on our
show it's just magnificent to watch it's
gonna be one of those you're watching
you're just through your fingers because
you're embarrassed for everybody
involved that you can't stop watching
what kind of Bachelorette has becca
become they really come into their own
as the season how would you describe her
now that filming is all wrapped I like
to say you only get a small snapshot
when they're on the show is one of the
25 you'll see Becca come in neurone
you're really gonna get a better glimpse
of the strong independent woman she is I
think people feel like oh is she just
this nice pushover she is not she's a
badass woman that can handle her own
trust me and I'm very defensive of my
bachelorettes she doesn't need it she
took care of herself many times we're
gonna hear let's do the damn thing too
many
I apologize right away I know people are
angry about that it's but it's in the
can and so you're gonna get it I
apologize I just tell you right now
don't reach out on social media it's
done it's over deal with it it's like
the Royal Wedding deal with it
[Music]